she'll hire smiley Evelyn and ash for
America's Whitney Whitney letraset
lasagna vicious a loser the professor
Maria and Oscar I don and nasha nasha
Nikita young donatus wanna score the
professor Josie washko Finola me lima oh
how will an Akuma be sugar and legume
yamean why he then why did thank you all
each of you i would like to thank
Whitney Center for the Humanities for
their hosting of this event I'd like to
thank the University Press and John Doe
nitesh for their publishing of the book
and I'd like to thank professor associ
for expressing and understanding what I
have been trying to do now speaking for
myself I'd like to also thank everyone
already mentioned and I'd like to thank
the staff at the Yale University Press
that I worked with Nev and all the
others whose names are like hot butter
on a very hot skillet have something to
disappeared
yeah what we've been doing in our
readings I keep trying to run away from
the microphone but the microphone is
following me what we've been doing in
our readings is this better is reading
Arabic and English but usually more
English and also what we've done is we
have in some cases not read exactly
matching text I was not able to
translate all that Airport has written
and sometimes he takes a direction that
I don't know but we're agreed that there
will be more English than than arabic
which a little bit of a bias towards the
English but those of you who are
bilingual will get a full share so we
will start with some English and since
we are in the sand also is a kind of all
made endless Ian moment so we will begin
with the season of tears which rubbers
references in a way falcon Akash Abdul
Rahman ADA it falls quiet the call of
the wilderness clouds traipse above the
palms and from the edge of the groves
the towers are tinted rose it falls
quiet the call of return I asked her and
Damascus does not answer does not come
to the strangers a will he stop here if
he passes by he doubt died without a
sound without a secret to his name I
live where she sleeps among her long
exhales in the weeping fields in the bed
spread by her tears in the small hallway
between her eyelids and sky it falls
quiet the call of return of my life
nothing remains in my eye except the sad
ghosts still the trees that weep on the
city's ground our lovers who sing my
songs mirror of endless wandering
changed the face of the moon for My
Beloved's face is no longer there
yesterday we climb toward that star saw
him in the moon nude saw him clothed
than what we saw struck us a face made
of dirt changed the face of the moon now
that her face is no longer their own
mirror of endless loss it falls quiet
the call of return I walk and the
Euphrates alongside me walks the trees
follow like flags and a pair of eyes
from the embers of use I sway with the
swaying waste of the beast I dance with
a black star and the towers our melody
is displaced from their scores my body
and its captors are in one land my heart
and its owners elsewhere it falls quiet
the song of return and the towers our
country of tears if she'd only known
she'd have wept the Euphrates and its
banks of Palms it falls quiet the song
of return confused confused i own a
choked language that waves towers i own
confused crucify and a tempted by a
terror in its depths tempted to rage
confuse the shores rub my inheritance
the waves defend my dawn i sang of
gardens and a towering palace while in
wet etching nests in attics head tell
him who used to sleep on soft cushions
that the heights are being punished by a
star tell him to ride through the
specter of hardship or he'll become
lowest of men it falls quiet the song of
return only myself I roll my history
slit it's throat in my hand rouse it
back to life I Shepherd my eliz torture
my mornings I feed them night and feed
them Mirage I have a shadow that fills
my earth and lengthens its ease and
greens it burns its past and like me
burns itself and we live together walk
together the same green language and our
lips and in the face of mid morning
light and in the face of death are ways
Park it falls quiet the song of return I
dream of Damascus of Tara in the shadow
of cassie young a past era stripped of
its eyes of a calcified body wordless
tombs calling out Damascus died here and
let your promises burn calling out
Damascus die and never return you chased
way of fat enthuse woman offered to
whomever comes your way to chance to a
daring Wayfarer sleeping through fever
and through ease in the arms of the east
I do your eyes in my book I carried you
a debt on my youth in the greenness of
water your foothills of cassie young
woman of moderns in temptress made of
like a city Damascus once your name
yesterday poetry daylight and I reach
Hotah and storm the gate of Hope howling
at trees howling at water and feels
weaving out of them an army and a flag
to wait our black sky your black sky and
Damascus our hands continue to weave
nothing not even death can dissuade us
when will we die Damascus when will we
find ease and last night in dream damask
I state I shaped the statue of clay in
his white curves i planted your history
damascus and i began in terror and enjoy
to fall like a quick on the hill of the
league i embraced her stroked her and
sang mm-hmm crescent moon and I said no
you will remain in longing Damascus and
in my blood and I said let Damascus burn
I my murder depths rose calling out to
Damascus they're frightened cries woman
of disobedience without certainty woman
of acquiescence woman of hubbub and
Chuck woman of veins filled with forest
and swamp naked woman lost to her thighs
listening to the dead to grave students
listening to pious ears in love with
your yellow corpses your victims feeding
on mud and tears City all eaten up
Damascus feeding on skin and hide oh
love no oh damascus if it were not for
you I would not have fallen into these
gorgeous would not have torn down these
walls would not have known this fire
that calls out that thugs our history
and illuminates vessel of the world
coming our way pardon me Damascus you
sinner beatified by your sins
ada enough azu ayodhya lady lamb tomate
bad kaifa haru asian hottie ality tanta
hey boo fiat fossil aura pas que far as
Cano with a karate wha hyah halogen min
al an Avila Emma he'll say n mo baina
Katie fea hazaron you jajaja scars hella
Havana to Regina to figure cetera foo of
Iran para halu hallelujah and add hula
FISA Burton van roon oh boy hallelujah
nas na minerally sudah 10 lira Atiyeh
one estelle ta hajur on a sua da da ba
da da hell alia and Adonijah sadi busy
till alla van a majority p nom nom la la
cala lazily vatta known in la ta vou me
Lottie Tata baharu min bajar de chartres
a weenie weenie Rossini a yeah to hob
dodo dodo yellow hottie yeah Betty Oh
dolly ki Tammy matin theory as al wakil
wafaa guru miss Mickey Hawaii Liliana
kill hi hello Liliana kill Abu I will um
la enana Alamo and Ibaka hua ab kiya
fiki an utter Ajima asha an aldose
kubicki where Tasha whatta spoken ha I
Qamishli Nawaf iza banaya diary
athleta we are men asobi la caca de
Icaza ottawa luffy keelin assassin yeah
bottom infamous ama vayan foofy faraji
Laurel a casa de lucchi aku new minja
didn't until Jessa do laddie you samal
radha kuala de las ad yiruma Nardo Terry
who was a ana Ana resume insula Letty
khatri word détente' kado aunt a mood
atomo wazoo wat added a toshiba benelli
was no deal ha ha ha he'll hire to the
reader on vaca lumen an takuna johan
lara violatin tetas jaha movie hulan min
and Vasilisa valleyca same metana are
all voila Leo belsher eaten yet ago
salut min la hago tentative Otto
linhares oh BTW wot da hello boy you pon
la langue Hara Jubei et vous de hielo
boggy finale hakata khatri world attend
taka do anta muta resume in salalah te
ha ido illusion me redo an akuna
seminian the bowl la redo and aesthetic
redo and differing maps of matter
to section where can I hold my feasts of
survival how can i release my wings
weeping in the cages of language and how
can I live in memory that they choked
with debris well a stone or a puppy
sprout between my shoulders will the
animals caged inside me escape will I
doze off and betray my limbs will I make
plugs out of dirt to stop on my lungs
and lie on the black stone of our
obedience will i anoint myself with
injured oil and stuff my throat was yes
yes no no no I have no country except
for these clouds rising as mist from
lakes of poetry shelter me dodd letter
dodd guard me dodd my language my home I
hang you like a charm around the throat
of this era and explode my passion in
your name not because you are a temple
not because you are my father or mother
but because I am I dream of laughter and
I whip through you so that I translate
my insides and cling to you as I tumble
as my side shutter like windows shaken
by a wind now just let loose from God's
fingers it is through you that I turn
into a breath that falls from the skies
lips and blows into the earth genitals
this is how I embrace you and say again
you are the body that names tomorrow and
it is on you that the dice of history
are tossed to make a mirror that
deserves me and to see myself reflected
in it to shape a space wide enough to
contain my heart maybe out put on a
shirt
with ripped sleeves or walk in tattered
socks and shoes maybe I'll slip a clouds
vein and sake my thirst maybe I'll
whisper home and only the history of a
dervish fated to die will be revealed to
me maybe I'll cover his grave with my
voice or try to uproot the Eiffel Tower
and replace it with a sapling of
demoscene jasmine or maybe I'll invite
adam back to earth so that he can build
a house for his beloved on earth and
call his children home now the Sun comb
the hair of dust and the bars of Paris
rise up like the version in her ascent I
summon angels and ambulances I turned
into water and flow in the pool of my
sorrows or I become a horizon and
climbed the heights of desire I know
that we die only once and our many times
we born and I know that death is only
useful if we live it too I know that the
hereafter is this rose this woman and
that a human face is the other side of
the sky I know that my skies will rise
from the Eden's of Earth cloud by cloud
welcome to history to its specks of dust
how can a mortal despair when the wind
is his Road
it's in section 9 and the last section
of this poem this is I from among my
race I waft like perfume this is I from
among my race I waft like perfume from a
dying rose I move slow sirs I spread and
like a bee I make my own honey this life
is cold not even a wound nothing but
machinery crowding the fields of human
birth there is no day or night only an
endless thread of disconnected moments
the outside is no home for me the inside
can find me among my ways I waft like
perfume from a dying rose I have no wish
to name I want to be exalted like light
I do not want to hold fast any longer I
want to run alongside the wind
concerto for 11th September concerto for
11 sep tember 2001 bc rest your backs
against the decidas of god or surrender
to the wheels of the machine he the
Defiant one will chart the lower layers
of creation empowered with water that
carries desire in an essence have led
and half myths in the avalanche of limbs
where the elements are shot and matter
is shattered 11 sep tember 2001 bc 11
sep tember 2001 ad the science of
another rhythm to conjoin nature and
algae throat and sword wind and soul and
to you my people you may applaud the
blood gushing from the vein of goodness
and you may prostrate to the divinity of
desire in the temples of evil in the
flood of metal geysers in waterfalls of
fire and stars carpeted with ash Apollo
God lover beloved can you still
distinguish between a face and a pair of
buttocks and you banished and despise
one rejoice and celebrate paradises here
they're under your feet he the Defiant
one will sharp the lower layers of
creation and dive into them into the
deepest depths he writes another history
for voice alphabet and word to his white
is a dromedary like immoral Isis to his
leftist spaceship sod but desert that
never stops screaming ein the work of
the wind and the belly of sand how the
dream of a body that saw everything
while
still in the womb rain the star sang
yeah the warrior king said do not
believe everything wind I ask nothing of
you except obedience and you sky where
were you why were you slow to respond
when I invited you noon a sobbing in the
throat of history Avaris deck heart hey
go where are your brains now in Tiberias
on the hudson or between them in a
webbed rocketship the present is a
slaughterhouse and civilization and
nuclear inferno and what do you say
about human beings each of whom lives
inside a ball of ice and has only one
dream where it is throw on the surface
of mercury and say who colonizes the
imagination of the West how can the hand
of virtue grass Moses his staff and
explode the fury of war and how did a
thousand and one nights become a
thousand and one armies and say who had
turned divinity into a form of
entertainment my certainty resides in
the house of a spider and what is this
crumbling among the ruins of orbits not
a planet and not a machine to conquer
planets it's the poet e of matter oh how
now more than ever my senses need to
read the holy books with the eye of
poetry Buddha will be happy buddha reads
with his body and loves poetry the lower
layers of creation calf noon coincidence
is the creatures home not the end of
words not the seed of knowledge the
lower layers of creation camouflage of
innards technology what are you
inflicting now on the body of the
universe no matter how deep
you doubt you will never reach the
hearts unknown and how miserable you are
gift of art one brush breaking another
one ink murdering another ink the lower
layers of creation of lamb rain
Guantanamo a prison administered by
capitalism on a communist Island a space
flooded with alphabets like the clay of
which Madame was made the earth is a
[ __ ] you said but is she not the mother
of all the angels she del human animal
shapes of all sorts are slaughtered and
squared draw on the tables of time blood
spilled as if it is seeping from the
gardens of god meme the enslaver the
enslaved an adulteration or modification
of the dualism of master slave seen
sheen sanctifying death virtue that is
evil evil that is virtue and thought
that is merely wash water in the
beginning was crime what do they want
those who do not want peace or justice
and do not want terrorism st. juste for
example how is there anything human in a
human being thou no revenge without
justice thus spake Aeschylus revenge
first this is how New York speak you
have done well Jim Morrison speaking of
an American night a moral case Elmo
tanabe Alan RSA who can now speak well
of this planet this Arab night and how
tired the earth must be truly from the
struggle between noon yeah and calf the
world's tragedy began meme a procession
launches the birth of planets dragged by
a soldier star legs led by blonde men
where we read the history of humanity in
a new translation etched on the page of
memory with a plastic chisel
and in the forests of uranium mushrooms
we build an oven that offers this
bacterial word I wish I knew how to tie
the flag to the strings of dream I would
have entered the bed of an oyster or
mated with a tree open my chest wide
where are your arms Jasmine tree and you
migrant bird is it better to be hunted
in the land of your migration than to be
choked in your pamphlet parents bed do
not forget to kiss for me the first
branch that received your wings and I
will kiss in your name the air for no
reason except to test the chain that
clamps my lips
naruto naruto as a looong confessor ah
hell nah haddad right was happy holiday
it emerged a seaman fickle Leo's name
ramatuelle phase Ronchetti fish at a
mill awanee sale too nadan alleluia
Sunni Sal to santa helper at hotoke
Anina llama still baba ke Masha Allah
Zawahri keyword olweus Uhuru Accardo
astro yummy wangsa thiru damiana voice
mija una borracha yahoo via similar
measure our o rly bond relieve an
artifact adobe ETF Elaine Oh shallow
dolma sabe la kina ha la to do nawaf EW
abdel-fattah nawafil la la la la to do
lalia Phil Bobby alka dia an ahool in a
fee voucher a lil baby s ooh la la ooh
la la ooh la la wanna miss lose your
head ya allah allah bore Elena's ef'n
yahoo lil hope yahoo min aina yet you
bria versa ma da kalma the early
Dinah Yantis baha FIFA ba ba GI na e con
la la radula hobby watchu doin la Reed
ultima and voila NASA bad via la reduce
Eva anukunna luva 10 lil jamuna obsidia
the rose leaves hurts flower bed to meet
her the Sun is naked in autumn nothing
except a thread of cloud around her
waist this is how love arrives in the
village where i was born in her name i
do not wish to exist so to exist I make
my lights plays and track my time in her
embrace and I sing to us and sing to her
in her name friend of my capture her
luminous body teach me how to sing again
I wake and ask dawn about you have you
woken I saw your face sketched around
the house on every branch I carried dawn
on my shoulder she arrives or is it the
dream tempting me I asked the dew on the
branches I asked the Sun have they
where'd your footsteps where did you
touch the door how did they walk
alongside you the roses and the trees
I'm about to break my days and split
into my blood there my body here sheets
of paper dragged into the ruined world
by sparks
when we meet wherever our steps take us
in cities or feels let silence enter its
wound speech do you want my love to have
a face that lights the sky then let your
eyes become a house for my face take me
talk I cannot feel the rhythm of my body
in your hands and eyes unless you speak
moon how kind the moon is when it comes
and draws water from her pool then says
goodbye fleeing how kind the bed the
mattress the covers where our limbs used
to entangle in a long embrace as we
begged the angel of wakefulness to walk
his bridge but to slow his pace how kind
the planets were they sang whenever
everything brought us together and
undressed our news
last one I will not sing my song no song
if it is not burdened with the
bitterness of love and what the winds
folly leaves suspended in the air no
song unless its equivalent emerges from
the edge of weeping m hua jai ho ho
yekta a few ways aha yahuwah jaha who
yep te fue hecho ya top Adama wat phu
tell vasuki fit not owned by federal a
wall yet academy octo anal mcconnell
Ozzie touch me no feel hyah that academy
otama I yet origin an OSD a key feature
a dirty de me voir pula until muna who
adoro to wall karato idea to zalazala
yet adamu you lil loafie an high and
Otto Otto salut well walk to yahoo you
high atal bihari t yahoo geminal waffa
waffa tata vasuki alaya wash ahaha le t
le le maza hai na da healthy a hospital
hulu test Alou Bacchanalia da igual on
our wall amada kulala let encanto ammulu
la habana de aqui Lily Latin mobila holy
voila robotica to Robin whoa filter ET
la la alivelu westerville maha dorati
washer be no
oudhia a few luenell top in a stereo poo
wast as Mary Ann hi aul Han Solo
mutinous guru million a llama y del y
baja antal resolver to wanaka Permian a
wall yes a dookie ew ew wass farrugia
auntie Sookie Arden la I refuah Hazuki
worth even hide and rust Eden voila
ahkna a very key ah who do ki Fateh
nuh-uh dirty faaliyaha don't even know
me philh a little woozy tati josey mayor
julián wakad ah who do kissin Ayrton
Senna Latin hasta tu masala key at amada
do fiki la Sol a tad owaru Lhasa Atta
Sulaco antisera Lassa Lassa lumen-a
Fosse colossal model myself AT&T model
massager tea auntie jane wawona de Vaca
whatta van t lantee at irukku sogliato
liseth chala Hatton Lee Valley sadly i
hadn't who tati offical Enoch toten mins
acid ET une ville a sudden receive
cotton Lee you'd only litter oh when I
settle murata Arden Lee acta seeable
photo osaka cool Mousa Lisa V habla de
irritated America deidara Osaka cool
huija Bill Miller Hallia Rizzuto and
midori Helena's hammock at integra Wilma
actor o Shahu cotton min al hajri hella
dalla aburro mahadji till Hadari
Stesha fatma a total Eliza rafanan the
world second ama hashing shuttle malad
at irukku for salut Mahara cotton well
Africa banal Camry was only a loss for
e-value awesome I Yubari boo fishery
Anil Maserati is teslim Larry hey Tasha
Rodolfo da lil faba young she became a
tousled it happy mantha little help from
body he erases his face he discovers his
face rupture advances a temptation
where's you in her first dawn time
advances where do you can tackle life
and how darkness advances what trainer
will spread you woman among my blood
cells so that I'll say you are climate
turn and sphere what aftershock light
advances it becomes night in my regions
I am torn and assemble time takes the
shape of skin and escapes time and your
conquest befell me my metamorphosis
heave toward you when you entered why
did you take the burning feels even
though my hands were the first fire and
why every night did I carry the softness
of your breasts to another night and a
woman with dirt on your knees the dirt
of the road that leads to you to
mountains and the cypresses of the
mountainsides and the largest of the
valleys I say we shall meet separate and
I will gather my regions bitter apples
that scatter like salt on tables of
licentiousness you are the sweetest and
I offer you the first taste of me your
body is a loss I leave behind
and you are the books of my departure I
take you al and I do not know hills and
valleys covered with the herbs of
seeking mysterious stretches and I take
you standing sitting lying none but you
convinces me I take you in the size and
waking in sleeps in my size in waking in
sleep in the states between in what time
promises me I take you fold by fold and
I open my entries to you I stretch
within you and do not reach I circle and
do not reach I stretch like why I thread
myself into yarn i Rove your expenses
and do not which you are beyond
distances beyond victories you are where
and if and what and how and when and you
are not you the good road is not good
for me and my steps belong to no one in
each dot on my body is a false clue a
rib is not a lover a sign that misleads
the roads and woman is not earth so that
I am forced to wear the sky I make the
triangle that its vertices the circle
doubt its radius I make bread suspicious
of salt will I find all the fixed habit
leap out of its orbit and am I a fish
that hates water it is all older than
stone it is older than stone this muscle
it has crossed all rationale for stupor
it has discovered oceans of nonsense
with them we followed the arc of a
sunflower we lived with them among the
Angels grass the road is made of limbs
and motions there is no difference
between the moon and its shadow the bird
and its branch and I see the see through
the forest skirts ice becomes king of
water yes unguarded me the galaxy's
circumference was my orbit I ram's horn
carries me a bull's lips
choose me I witness how light becomes
the body of thorns how mud releases the
moans of the sky how truth erases me and
delusion oats me how do I cross the
distances between them there is always a
distance between us you striking into
the artery of distance surrender to the
wind that scatters space into its the
space that walks with the feet of a
child to love to love that has become
the Exile of love delicately flu zelika
the flu levy cunto attorney Margaret Ann
version very even wlkn machine vaca lana
y r mughal ahora SI some dead otona
naran Yuri were even Jamaat nuh Bismack
has a lower octave rev3 low so low bosca
rakhna alberton tech tobu a lardo what
are we alpha so I you have to flu leti
hoon toh takada melody yes ma la llamada
Sanna ho thank you